[Applaudissements]
il ya une sorte de dictature de la
pensée d'un troll qui es tu moi je suis
du ruban excusez-moi de manic
[Musique]
mais
je suis maire de ce village de machado
dont l'un des premiers
députés
[Applaudissements]
elle a levé un lièvre on reste dans le
thème
[Applaudissements]
pour moi ce sont les chasseurs et les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs sont des
régulations effectivement et moi je le
vois sur mon territoire si je vous
raconte pas des trucs j'ai lu et ouais
mais vous lisez beaucoup de conneries ou
de bouquins mais moi je suis sur le
terrain je meilleur du réal et je peux
vous assurer que je les côtoie tous les
jours un agriculteur je vais sur le
terrain avec eux j'apprends comme votre
définition du naturalisme mieux ensemble
parce que moi je vais sur le terrain
avec eux souvent les dimanches voir ce
qui se passe c'est pas des assassins
alors il sait pas que moi pour cela la
régulation il ya des élevages de gibier
j'avais tout nous mais qu'elle les
efforts
des gars
n'ont même jamais écouté nationale des
producteurs de gibier
je pensais sincèrement que le gibier
c'est que l'affairé est terminée
par exemple du sanglier samedi
on a la même île je parle sous le
souhait couvert de du député mais c'est
bien nourrie par les chasses savez
combien même à nourrir et de dégâts at
on créé un sanglier en france et 80
millions d'euros ce sont les chasseurs
qui ps tous ces dégâts aux agriculteurs
les agriculteurs aux essais mais coûteux
oui mais qu'est ce que font les
agriculteurs sur leur terrain et cultive
pommes de terre du maïs tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer ça nous fera bouffer et
ben voila et les animaux moment donné
c'est qu'on régule et si les chiens
sellers qui paye les dégâts des
voûtes vivait dans qu'elle mangeait en
voie de les lâcher de 100 kg
formé par vous confondez pas d'accord
alors
aller sur internet oui lâche de s'en
lasser
par rachid sanguinaire phrases comme ça
c'est
si vous parlez aux sangliers qui est un
être humain il va vous parler avant d
aller au point de colle ça ressemble
beaucoup à la chaîne sangliers
jean marie laborde à la question très
importante c'est que moi je suis pas
chasseur ses portes à gainville n'est
pas de partir mais chassez de ma vie
d'accord mais j'ai envie de dire non il
faut pas interdire la chasse qu'il
faille elle à réguler parce que quand on
me dit à
95,96 espèces et cetera et cetera c'est
qu'ils sont en voie de disparition il
faut arrêter certainement ça c'est clair
mais pourquoi l'être certains chasseurs
d'abord tout ce que vous avez dit ils
aiment leur territoire il s'en occuper
d'accord dans tout ce qu'ils font j'ai
envie de dire le public n'a pas à le
faire ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième des choses effectivement c'est
la régulation alors et vous vous dites
aller sur internet avec sur google a les
yeux sinon c'est sur le terrain qu'il
faut bien sûr c'est sur le terrain qu'il
faut aller encore écouter quelques mois
que je parle avait des gens qui changent
chasseurs d'accord jamais ils me disent
on lâche si on alors là on a élevé pour
le nord
c'était pourtant après il ya un côté
social aussi fait ce monde rural à
chasser c'est un rendez vous à 17 années
oui au delà de la tradition tesco
veulent un côté social comme certains
vont au bistrot faire l'apéritif le soir
etc terrain il ya déjà que me suis
retrouvé mené par des gens qui vivent en
somme et moi je n'étais pas prêt moi je
suis mes cheveux bien comme moi moi
c'est le cas d'aurélie c'est à lui qu'on
doit rencontrer
jeudi bien supprimée acharnement des
années mais beaucoup chercheurs me
disent oui qui sont elles vont dans ce
sens mais alors à ce moment là quand je
vous écoute vous voudriez tout et
dernier essai
c'est tout mais je dois faire ce que
j'ai à faire s'il faut pas faire ça
laissez nous vivre dit peu
après pour être bien clair et bien
répondre à votre question est-ce qu'il
faut réguler le gibier ou est-ce qu'il
faut réguler certaines activités de
chasse je pense que votre question c'est
réglé les activités de choses sur lui
vous avez tout à fait raison oui je suis
tout à fait en phase il faut moderniser
un certain nombre de pratiques vous
entendre il faut moderniser mais sachez
ses coûts ce qui était dans les cordes
pour ce qui est terrible ce qui est
terrible vous êtes centre ce qui est
terrible et je peux terminer notre sujet
on va l'aborder nous la chasse toutes
les années l'achat se fait des efforts
chaque année la chasse évolué sur les
pratiques sur lucas que l'usagé du plomb
on en a déjà parlé avec monsieur rigaud
sur la sécurité est en face de nous nous
n'avons des personnes qui de manière
dogmatique veulent interdire la chasse
et tous les efforts qui sont faits par
le peuple de phrases ce chasseur pas
pour le peuple de phrases le peuple de
france et chasseurs il arrive un moment
où ils en ont marre et quand ils sanomat
mais ils descendent dans la rue comme le
week-end dernier et quand ils en ont
marre ils le disent haut et fort et donc
il faut arrêter de penser que nous
sommes des gens totalement archaïque
coincés dans nos points qu'on ne veut
rien changer
la seule chose qu'on connaît de nous je
le dis à chaque fois c'est le sketch des
inconnus alors là on nous le ressort
bande de d'alcoolo tuer la cocotte froid
de ce sketch je comprends mais oui
c'est très bon
ou fausser le débat sur l'armée ça nous
fait un débat sur l'armée vous ne parlez
pas de la grande vadrouille comme si
c'était la référence de ce militaire
nous ne parlons pas de la chasse à
velaux ce qu'a déjà connu comme si
c'était la référence universelle et oui
il
faut interdire la chasse complètement il
faut alors il faut l'interdire
complètement pas tout de suite pas
demain parce que ça quand même à
quelqu'un de raisonné de responsables
des loges tout
chaud pour une régulation un encadrement
strict parce qu'aujourd'hui ça part dans
tous les sens une réflexion une
réflexion pour à l'horizon je sais pas
2030-2040 cesser la chasse pour ma
génération je vous avoue que la chasse
est ce que c'est une nécessité
aujourd'hui en 2021 non est ce que c'est
un loisir oui tout simplement je vais
même dire je vais peut-être choquer des
gens pour moi c'est un petit plaisir
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
la d'activité
quand je peux parler
merci bruno là on avait vu la main sur
ce même plateau des vidéos de chasse à
courre et moi je vous avoue que j'ai pas
forcément une fibre annie animal comme
je peux dire sans pop citadins qui
s'expriment sur la fin on va peut-être
consulté de vieux con j'ai eu un peu
peur mais moi je t'avais tête quand je
vois des vidéo clubs un jeune con quand
je vois des vidéos quand je vois des dix
lots de chasse à courre belgique une
énorme et demi que j'ai qu'une envie
c'est vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi terminer on est passé
rapidement sur les 100 sur les en
s'aidant de chasse je suis parti sur un
compte instagram et je conseille
vraiment à tout le monde d'aller le voir
qui s'appelle un jour un chasseur qui
recense des témoignages d'incidents de
chasse quotidien ouais bien sûr mais
aussi
cédé 0,7
vous assumez pas
mal actuellement je parle d'encadrement
est-ce que ça dérangerait les chasseurs
qui est des jours de chasse encadré que
par exemple le week-end en famille
puisse se promener tranquillement en
forêt à avoir peur de
[Applaudissements]
l'encadrement un encadrement des permis
de chasse amant cadre meilleure des
écoles et la population est aujourd'hui
mais dire qu'il est beau tout
est vraiment
gênant du tout on ne vit pas je vais
faire un gros but je fais pas un
raccourci sur les chasseurs je le presse
la suite je suis non mais je ne sais pas
ce que je vais dire encore et le finir
il ya eu des féminicides d'accord ont
même connu d'armes à feu je veux dire je
vais le dire ça peut-être choquer les
gens mais je vais le dire que les armes
à feu très souvent c'est un revenait de
la chasse c'est sur moi
m
10h15
[Applaudissements]